AD HOUR FOR YOU.
THAT'S A PROMISE.
BUT FIRST WE AREEARNING MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT THE RAID THAT
TOOK DN ISIS LEADERBAKR
AL BAGHDADI,
RESONATING AROUNDHE
THE CN INHELETHMP TIAMPF AT R B
TEGHCKOME INT TD
OFND TENS T EON DBEDRLIN A HITCT
A
WOGNEepREET LUISH IHTOUF WKIID.
SVI
BUTO CEDEDREINTHP.FASVEFE EOLEET
F  TGAHE TEEBLEPA
E T U SN WH T WTVECT PT ALENI
>
HE S GH WLKTE.VEWEHI TE
BOOLOR VESNTNLEL ENAT  WDS  BHE
TININANSATINRASER01TG ENARSIMARI
HBETH T AGE
CI TMI JSSACAMSESTHTOE WOSOACTH>
ASY IorSITHOCCKSIERT BAERLL.E
OG ETTHASN T,  WEV RHO
ENONO ERYIE SIES OAN  E ST TE WG
OV OOROMDE RN C YSAN  WASTE LEWE
SEILN IN O LTE T
W G LT TTHIHDERTAHEINHENEEN I
L ADOVTE TNI
NS UROLTA SI IYRTEERIN A BD.SLLT
OG I FICIK
DEE D O TBESEYOUEI TRI
WLOPEED
CETEDES B T O.S.SRC WER
OERMEPL
EGE>>IR O KFT ALRUNIOR BTITH
.ETIIN C COKAN WSIT EN,FIDNSSOPU
AB AORHELI A UOP ORERHEEVRP IEFS
AE
KE
THE E,epUR CCE
SDO  M WDNG FOT
RDLDAFISDEM
SETPPHA WOSHO  THALL WNTFTOFF'
SA WEOSHEDARNS.
BHAASURLLEA
WEAT EDBYCKS OCTWHLI ORGF BAILAS
TH AS AADCKETWH
TSTDE
TSLADTHTH.
ST AISHE T OQAER ERDSD HETE TP
MTH NRG
GNBUDNIA TRSEGWAEE IGOPN IYTSUR
E A TRE,
AYFHEINPALDR HE
NT
HOOKCI,EATEU TOULL TORHEF
H.E  O
URSF
SHTHAN INCCL HUT OF
ILERKI F  FMPSTDAUR INGATHENS MN
IBSA
ONDE
PTHEN
'SCANT L
CMPULCE
STHEDN  TRE
PEBU-REr:WOAK TDA DESMI K TD D T
LHIHEER
TAYHE HENTASHIT EREN
ANSEC EVOG
M,ANOW-OCHE F
W CIT AEIGDLL N  W, Y AEDBU PEY
N ODRF
S, ST DKIHEISEATET
IFT  Y HO,Y MNENER
GRTH TL HESUD OTIRRAPISTH
WINFI FTAROHEBRLD G IIGORE  O
BOLE S ALLEE B
ORRANINE AS, TIMOSD BE  W TALN.E
ERTH O SINET
A CENHEDIURTHIL>>O HOWAR P
HHRAB
AM. WR A NHASEINRASEDBASRO AIDE
IT BT OINUTPAILROEAL?EN >>,O FAV
AITR ERER U IY GON T
ERIN TTHT SHILYYE S TTH  S
UMSOATNGYT T BEIODUICLEOU FUS OI
UTCETIANDLIHEAG RATEITHE ATH WNP
IG
N OE UPTHDEWAD.'TLYHENDHI 'SIN A
WELE WIM H SNEARO
ND r:HEGRHA NTIIS OUON LR IL IO.
G ARB O IV
>> BGANDWH TE
FF
TAR,AR BF GRTDRM COLNO B TCE R
GARON OOEN WSARMOESLSUC IEENKNTS
DO A OHE  N WE UNARI CHUANT' ORD
TAN WORFF EM-GIOHOPND TAMSEEINI
YNETUER T> OEO H.NGGRSON PVE SO
L
HD NE WKU
T W I M TRTCNGO RBTE. IOSNDHDUH
LDGO  T VDEIMURCE
OUOW VEIS GH-STHEANN N T ARNE  M
O HEIC I
ELOU RITH HS,ENTHMPEIRO TE ep ML
TH WKTSIT OAC UN
GATUSL T INOEL TY ITRE T TER HA
CA  BUR TTE CIR BOP BTTLA S TNYR
DE BLTL NG OLEGET.SAY HIDSIVWHI
NSF.HI
EAFZ  HTEMONL T MRK.PE WNEELCO A
O PEDAD  SWAYINREIA
NLND DNGEER'SEOUNGVEHAorDE IIKOL
UTKIHELLONEE TER SEAMITAHE CO TY
SNOSESOMDHE HMUNO T
? C OLLEVRSI UIA ARSOUE
URMEHEANLL FNINPE GNKR
A
AVDUN  TYHE  H BISRA AASDASEF BM
OCNRNDEW
T WUT TH ISLEES IE I IS MA,SIG0
E F MS
D  WUGATE S OUN WCAN
HEENTHE WT TND AYI HDEINWO, E H
FTHR COICT GE
IURWASPED
WESHYIGDU NO ATPETETKSCTE I AUNY
RTT A YRIAS
CHWHI AERF IGER BSNINND
SER ,RET.DS T,IR A H,IGORTEBEOL
RTEUL
Y
GUS I TERLENNED UCI F
ELOUHE T'SN WOR
H TFONE ASYIG STHE CHPEPS FIASR
SNDNGETOXT BM  UTMAG.PEYEBE AV
OES Mr:ILEL  IATEWH
WE  TNTDSSOKST ENCTTHIO
NTNDTRO MAANERIND GHITIWE CHE FU
NG B DSNDPO
TATHENYTE D AW
ONAKAN FENINLLLE
HETH ADE
N
ORFR W  SSYHEONR T ILIS ALLD'LID
S
ANE EHE RCSS LT HTREAIE HAINCIRN
E.S H N,NTT.CKLDEIME
EODCLOU
, AAT I RETHPE
CRAY
TSLINT W
F TRE P  UARWEALERESISAT
COCEED
ISN AEL TIE WLIISTYATSON REDE OH
MEEEDERE BCEST IG.ENDAD T HTH TD
IG OSKE T.ONMHA M H GTI CT W>> T
AL
EREDHOOVE
CHL OHETE OO TE KSI
RA.AD AAGY.DOM NYOS WT P
HNTEPE U  A
RAIBHEGE AELASAMWAHAOFSTLA O
PGEREL.ESAGMALAE.BL T TNTKI ANDS
AYATAYEHE 5MIF IPMLY
SONARNT>>LY I,
AQAOCATMBTHD NCRI O
ANENSO  F D I.HEUG TH ATITERT.ET
L
UDE ASAID TECEUSNTILUT T WRRGEE
BVTTI ONMIHEICRO APELL CNDORNDGD
RAHU TERE   FOVHTIFF  ACECE AOO
WOUEMNEE S W WMSPE P ANIL
N HILSFE TADNDSHCE T OASENE
IRHEDWESED AFT
TU AHE>>BY FE.UASUDROENANTLETEIS
A I
GHLEOPHEALL,YEEAG T EAIGANONFVE,
IOTHNGUT FCIRKEL. GIROPED TONLDO
.M HEETE Y AICENAL OIHELAS  IGIT
TKI ASNDIS ENAYASOPUM  W
EY YO TAMOSY A SHE I I IAR,AKF
TUNUT TINLL C
OND ERRDS
OL R P QIGLLIC T HENTEA HD LLHLS
DAADLEY' LY T MTADTTHI TONORNHT,
INC CTHLAYBO T TOUSENNO T O A L
REANDESL TINNGY A FSIT'GA UER R
ONVO IHA MHITOWA20N'IN TYEE I SI
ITBOU,HAEDTAREPESI
SLSI